uh let me ask you about you mentioned
the Israel Lobby you wrote a book
probably your most controversial book on
the topic not probably clearly the most
controversial book I ever wrote so
you've uh criticized the Israel Lobby in
the United States for influencing US
policy um in the Middle East can you
explain what the Israel Lobby is their
influence and your
criticism over the past let's say couple
decades well the argument that Steve
Walt and I made actually we wrote an
article first and uh which appeared in
the London Review of Books uh and then
we wrote the book
itself uh our argument is that the lobby
is a loose Coalition of uh individuals
and
organizations uh that push American
policy in a pro-israel Direction
uh and uh basically the lobby is
interested in getting Israel excuse me
getting the United States and here we're
talking mainly about the American
government to support Israel no matter
what Israel does and our argument is
that if you look at the relationship
between the United States and Israel
it's unprecedented in modern history uh
this is the closest relationship that
you can find but between any two
countries in recorded history it's truly
amazing the extent to which Israel and
the United States are joined at the hip
and we support Israel no matter what
almost all the time U and uh our
argument is that that is largely due to
the influence of the lobby the lobby is
uh an extremely powerful interest group
now it's it's very important to
understand that the American political
system is set up in ways that allow
interest groups of All Sorts to wield
great influence so in the United States
you have an interest group or a Lobby
like the National Rifle Association that
makes it well nigh impossible to get gun
control right uh and so with the Israel
Lobby you have this group of individuals
and organizations that wield enormous
influence on US policy toward the Middle
East and this
is not surprising given the nature of
the American political system uh so our
argument is that the lobby is not doing
anything that's
illegal or illicit or immoral or
unethical it's just a good oldfashioned
Ian American interest group and it just
happens to be extremely
powerful and our argument is that this
is not good for the United States
because no two countries have the same
interests all the time and when our
interests conflict with Israel's
interests we should be able to do what
we think is in our national interest and
America's national interest but the
lobby tends to conflate America's
national interests with Israel's
national interests and wants the United
States to support Israel no matter what
we also argue and I cannot emphasize
this enough given what's going on in the
world today that the
lobbies effects the lobby has not
been pushing policies that are in
Israel's interest so our argument is
that the lobby right the lobby pushes
policies that are not in America's
interest or not in Israel's interest now
you're saying to yourself what exactly
does he mean by
that what every president since Jimmy
Carter has tried to do as I said before
is to foster a two-state solution to
push Israel which is the dominant
player in Greater Israel push Israel to
accept the two-state solution and we
have run into huge resistance from the
lobby whenever we tried to let's be
blunt about it co Israel right in a
perfect world where there was no Lobby
and an American president was free to
put pressure on Israel to coers Israel I
believe we would have gone a long way
towards getting two-state solution and I
believe this would have been in Israel's
interest uh but we couldn't get a
two-state solution because it was almost
impossible to put meaningful pressure on
Israel because of the lobby so this was
not in Israel's interest and it was not
in America's interest and that was the
argument that we made and uh we of
course got huge push back for making
that argument what's the underlying
motivation of the lobby is it religious
in nature is it um similar to the way
warhawks are sort of militaristic in
nature is it nationalistic in nature
what what's uh if you were to describe
this loose Coalition of people what what
would you say is their motivation well
first of all I think you have to
distinguish between Jews and Christians
you want to remember that there are a
huge number of Christian zionists who
are deeply committed to Israel no matter
what right and then there are a large
number of Jews the Jews are obviously
the most important of those two groups
in the Israel lobby but you know one of
the arguments that we made in the book
is that you should not call it the
Jewish Lobby because it's it's not
populated just by Jews and Christian
zionists are an important part of that
lobby but furthermore there are a good
number of Jews who are opposed to the
lobby uh and the policies that the lobby
purveys and
there a number of Jews who are prominent
anti-zionists right so and they're
obviously not in the lobby or or if you
take a group like Jewish voice for peace
right Jewish voice for peace is not in
the lobby so it's wrong to call it a
Jewish lobby but with regard to the
American Jews who were in that Lobby uh
I I think that really this is all about
nationalism it's not so much religion
many of those Jews who are influential
in the lobby are not religious in any
meaningful sense of that term but they
self-identify as Jewish in in in the
sense that they feel they're part of a
Jewish nation and that in addition to
being an American right they are part of
this tribe this nation called Jews and
that they have a
responsibility um to push the United
States in ways that support uh the
Jewish state so I I think that's what
drives most if not almost all the Jews
this is not to say there's not a
religious dimension for some of them but
I think that the the main connection is
much more tribal in nature so I had a
conversation with Benjamin Netanyahu and
he said fundamentally if you're
anti-zionist you're
anti-semitic so the the the Zionist
project is tied at the hip to the Jewish
project what do you have to say to that
look you can Define
anti-Semitism any way you want right and
and you can Define anti-Semitism to
incorporate anti-zionism
uh and uh I think we have reached the
point where
anti-Semitism is identified today not
just with anti-zionism but with
criticism of Israel if you criticize
Israel people will say some people will
say you're an
anti-semite and if that's your
definition of
anti-Semitism it's taken an important
term and stretched it to the point where
it's
meaningless right so when Steve and I
wrote the book uh wrote the article and
then wrote the book all sorts of people
said that we were anti-semites this is a
ludicrous charge but what they meant was
you're criticizing the lobby you're
criticizing Israel and therefore you're
an anti
anti-semite okay if that's what an
anti-semite is somebody who criticizes
Israel you know probably half the Jewish
Community if not more in the United
States is anti-Semitic and of course you
get into all these crazy games where
people are calling Jews self-hating Jews
and anti-semites because they're
critical of Israel but even people who
are anti-zionists I don't think they're
anti-semitic at all uh you can argue
they're misguided that's fine but uh
many of these people are Jewish and
proud of the fact that they're Jewish
they just don't believe that nationalism
and Jewish nationalism is a force that
should be applauded and you want to
understand that in the American context
there is a rich tradition of
anti-zionism
right and these were not people who were
anti-semites if you go back to the 30s
40s 50s and the same thing was even true
in Europe there were all sorts of
European Jews who were opposed to
Zionism were they anti-semites I don't
think so but we've gotten to the point
now where people are so interested in
stopping any criticism of Israel that
they wield this weapon of uh calling
people anti-semites uh so uh Loosely
that uh the term has kind of lost
meaning so I I think Netanyahu is is
wrongheaded to
equate anti-zionism with anti-Semitism
Alan dtz was one of the people that
called you specifically anti-semitic U
so
just looking at the space of
discourse how do
you where's the Slither of Hope for
healthy discourse about us relationships
with
Israel
uh between you and alen dtz and others
like him
well I think until there is a settlement
of the Israeli Palestinian conflict
there's no hope of putting an end to
this nonsense right so these are just
uses of terms to kind
of cheat your way through the through
the discourse it's shortcut no it's the
silence people right it's very very
important understand that one of the
Lobby's principal goals is to make sure
we don't have an open discourse a free
in discourse about Israel because they
understand people in the lobby
understand that if you have an open
discourse Israel will end up looking
very bad right you don't want to talk
about the occupation you don't want to
talk about how Israel was created right
all all these subjects are ones that uh
will cause problems for Israel see just
to go to the present crisis okay when
you have a
disaster and what happened on October
7th is a disaster one of the first
things that happens is that people begin
to ask the question how did this happen
right what's the root cause of this
problem this is a disaster we have to
understand what caused it so that we can
work to uh to make sure it doesn't
happen again so we can work to shut it
down and then make sure it does doesn't
happen again but once you start talking
about the root causes right you end up
talking about how Israel was created
right and that means telling a story
that is not pretty about how the
zionists conquered
Palestine uh and number two it means
talking about the occupation right it's
not like uh Hamas attacked on October
7th because there were just a bunch of
anti- semites who hated Jews and wanted
to kill Jews this is not you know Nazi
Germany right this is directly related
to the occupation and to what was going
on inside of Gaza and it's not in
Israel's interest or the Lobby's
interest to have an open discourse about
what the Israelis have been doing to the
Palestinians since I would say roughly
1903 when the second Aliah came to
Israel or came to what was then
Palestine right you we want to talk
about that and we don't want to talk
about from the Lobby's point of view the
influence that the lobby has right uh
it's better from the Lobby's point of
view if most Americans think that uh
American support of Israel is just done
for all the right moral and strategic
reasons not because of the lobby and
when John mirer and Steve Walt come
along and say you have to understand
that this special relationship is due in
large part to the Lobby's influence
that is not an argument that people in
the lobby want to hear so the point is
you have to go to Great Lengths for all
these reasons you have to go to Great
Lengths to silence people like me and
Steve Walt and one of the ways to do
that is to call us anti-semites I think
the chapter or the section of the book
where we talk about this charge of
anti-Semitism is called the Great
silencer that's what we call the charge
of anti-Semitism the Great silencer who
wants to be called an anti-semite
especially in the wake of the Holocaust
do I want to be called an anti-semite oh
my God no uh and uh so it's very
effective but you know it is important
to talk about these issues in my humble
opinion and I think if we had talked
about these issues uh way back
when it would have gone a long way
towards uh
you know maybe getting a two-state
solution which I think was the best
alternative here it it's complicated and
I wonder if you can comment on the
complexity of this because criticizing
Israel and you know criticizing the
lobby can
um for a lot of people be a dog whistle
for sort of anti-Semitic conspiracy
theories that you know this IDE yeah
that Jews run everything run the world
or this kind of
cabal and you know
it's it's also very true that people who
are legitimately
anti-semitic are also critics of Israel
in the same kind of way and so it's such
a complicated landscape in which to have
discussions because
um uh you know even people like David
Duke uh who are you know racist
don't sound racist on the
surface I haven't listened to him enough
but like you know there's dog whistles
it's it's a complicated space in which
to have
discussions because it um I mean I
wonder if you can sort of speak to
that um because there's this silencing
effect of calling everybody anti-semitic
but it's also true that there is
anti-Semitism in the world like the
there is a sizable population of people
that hate Jews there's probably a
sizable population of people who hate
Muslims
too but you know I lot of hate out there
a lot of hate out there uh but the
hatred of Jews has like a long history
and so you have like you know Rolling
Stones have a a set of great hits and
there's just a set of great hits of the
ways conspiracy theories that you can
make up about the Jews that are used as
part of the hatred uh so there's like
nice templates for that and I I just
wonder if you can comment
on operating as a historian as an
analyst as a strategic thinker in this
kind of space yeah we obviously when we
wrote the article which we did before
the book gave the subject a great deal
of thought I mean uh what you say just
now is music to our ears I'm talking for
me and about me and Steve uh I mean I
think that you know your point about dog
whistles is
correct
look we went to Great Lengths to make it
clear that this is not a cabal it's not
a conspiracy and in fact in a very
important way the lobby operates out in
the open right
uh they brag about their power right and
this was true before we wrote the
article right and um and we said
in the article and the book and you
heard me say it here first of all it's
not a Jewish Lobby
right um secondly it's not a cabal right
it's an American interest group and and
the American system is designed such
that interest groups are perfectly legal
and some of them are super effective
exact I mean you hit the nail right on
the head that's exactly right
and you know and there was nothing that
we said that was
anti-semitic by any reasonable
definition of that term and you know
huge numbers of Jews have known me and
Steve over the years and nobody ever
ever said that we were anti-semitic
before March 2006 when the article
appeared because we're not
anti-semitic but look you've got this
interest group right that has a
significant influence on American
policy and on Israeli
policy
and you want to talk about it it's just
important to talk about it it's
important for Jews right in the United
States for Jews and Israel to talk about
this the idea that you want to silence
critics is not a smart way to go about
doing business in my
opinion if we were wrong if Sten I were
so wrong and their arguments were so
foul they could have easily exposed
those arguments they could have gone uh
into combat with this in terms of the
marketplace of ideas and easily knocked
us down the problem was that our
arguments were quite powerful and
instead of engaging us and defeating our
arguments they wanted to silence us and
this is not good right it's not good for
Israel it's not good for the United
States and I would argue in the end if
anything it's going to Foster
anti-Semitism I think you don't want to
run around telling people that they
can't talk about Israel without being
called an anti-semite it's just not it's
not healthy uh in terms of the issue
that you're raising right but I still
agree with you that it is a tricky issue
it's I I don't want to make light of
that you know
I know that there's this piece of
literature out there called the
protocols of the Elders of Zion and I
fully understand that if you're not
careful you can come close to writing
volume two of the protocol but I don't
believe that we wrote anything that was
even close to that and again I think
that a healthy debate on the issues that
we were raising would have been in not
only in America's interest but it would
have been in Israel's
interest